now this is an important video to make
sure you're not consuming too much
protein so i want to tell you the top
sign to know that you're consuming too
much protein and the number one symptom
is
gastrointestinal malaise now what is
this gastrointestinal malaise well it's
a general discomfort an uneasiness in
your digestive system like you just feel
something's not right number two
dysphoria
there's some alteration in how you feel
dysphoria is a state of generalized
unhappiness restlessness dissatisfaction
or just frustration you just don't feel
very good and then we get number three
lethargy this is lack of energy
sluggishness
and just a lack of enthusiasm and number
four weakness
so all four of these
symptoms
can indicate that you're consuming too
much protein now on a ketogenic diet you
should never go past 30 of all your
calories being protein in fact i
recommend keeping your protein calories
roughly about 20
because what's going to happen is you
might start getting increased
bun blood urea nitrogen
and so you're going to get a lot of
protein waste and you may see your urine
being a bit foamy and having a very um
kind of a weird odor but here's the
thing the skeletal muscle protein
synthesis which is your dietary protein
turning into muscle protein and repair
occurs when you're consuming protein
you know up to about 25 grams per meal
but as you start to go over this number
you get less and less protein synthesis
and you're going to get more and more
oxidation where that protein is going to
be burned as fuel because it's going to
turn into sugar so if you were to double
that number let's say you're consuming
50 grams of protein per meal half of
that protein is not going to be used for
synthesis the creation of new muscle or
the repair of muscle it's going to be
used as oxidation or fuel now what's
this going to do to your keto plan it's
going to reduce your keto adaptation
it's going to increase your blood sugars
it's going to increase your insulin a
little bit not as much as sugar but it's
going to increase it to a modest amount
and it's going to drop your ketone
production so going on a keto plan is
not doing high protein it's doing a
moderate amount of protein
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i'd really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others